okay good luck
[Music]
sorry some fusion songs
well now I forgot my line
I know I approved this line before for a
World Cup match
is white
mosquitoes but
like turnips
you're a little tired no no
this position so tired
what about being on Earth from us
I'm old man no
I'm 37 years of age
are you actually yeah you don't look a
day past 30. yeah no no no one day past
30.
yeah um not one like maybe a few more
minutes
what's my when's my birthday I don't
know ah how do I know your birthday I'm
I'm true friend or also soccer I don't
know
December 5th
Levy you are 26 as well yeah
Rosen you're 27 or 28.7
9 yeah
you're 24 22.
but this kind of sucks this is 23 in
January it's very very tricky position
nice
ah can you stop beating me in the Brier
it's like a briar yes why does he have
two and a half minutes because I can't
figure out Briar Theory Antonio just
knows it perfectly
this is the worst exchange stock in the
other one I played I wonder if I can
like position feed it to give me like
points for that game not take any from
you just like I'll actually one last
game okay
if they get if if you could get like one
tenth of a norm every time you watch
someone who like I love like streaming
oh you get anything for that I'm like
yeah for flagging that GM
you get one tenth of a norm every time
you have a Grand Master on stream in
legitimate circumstances I I'd be I'd be
World Champion by now
um
[Music]
GG all right not playing The Briar
against you next time I'm gonna find
another line of students
yeah but okay that is Advantage yeah but
I'm gonna find a difference
there's only like 500 lines maybe I'll
play the schliemann the schliemens
is cool do you have a question no no no
uh yes not of course on it but of course
with it as a suggestion
yeah
I was asking foggy about that
oh my God
[Music]
oh
episode
okay you know this guy never resigned in
his life okay so some people and she had
said they thought you were tired Bubby
and someone else wants me to give them a
diamond membership yes but okay if they
want something nice yes I mean just
admit you you broke or something yes
I gave away Diamond memberships to nine
random people some showed up on site
yesterday what really just a bunch of
hands in the lobby that's hilarious
they're great they traveled from the
park we didn't have tickets for this
event
so people that have like gone out of
their way to come anyway and just tried
to do what I can do you think
oh my God we'll do these with tickets
soon
the future is right this this venue just
was not
feasible stuff but yeah
what have you done with this position
tonight
good job for not resigning yeah I was
you know
facility it's a game where I can't group
for no reason
ah if only I play Queen C5
[Music]
he wins yes oh